some of you may have already seen the
harrowing footage of our sky news team
caught under fire in kiev my goodness
they narrowly escaped russian soldiers
and managed to come back home safely
back to their families
here's how events unfolded
[Music]
the five of us have made it out of the
car down the embankment and we just
can't believe we're alive
okay guys welcome everyone i think
we run into a warehouse unit looking for
cover
yep
i'm pleased and
relieved to say that my colleague of
more than 30 years is here
uh there was a time when i thought that
it wasn't going to happen yeah tell us
what happened
it's been a there had been a curfew in
place in kiev for two days uh previously
because um the local authorities
security were actually looking for what
they described as saboteurs russian
saboteurs who they said had infiltrated
kiev
and um were there to to to carry out
attacks on civilians so we'd been in in
the city but the war was was was gaining
pace and we wanted to go to a town
called butcher which is just outside
kiev it's really a suburb actually and
it took us hours and hours to get there
through
probably 20 plus checkpoints that were
very jumpy and it was getting late and
and we just basically called it a day
and said we just can't get there the
battle space was changing helicopter
gunships such russians were in the air
and firing about a kilometer from where
we were and we basically decided to call
it a day
the routes that we had used to get to
try and get to butcher were now closed
they were actually part of the front
line
we stopped at a police checkpoint and we
asked what the best direction was back
to uh to the center of the city and they
pointed us down this road
probably no more than four or five
hundred meters away there was a bang on
the car
we i think the front uh left wheel had
blown and we weren't quite certain what
it was came to a stop and then
the firing started from what was an
ambush position both in front of the car
and on the left-hand side of the car
um
and
what's
one of the things that's interesting
about this case is is these incidents
happen a lot
it's that it's very rare that the camera
is rolling for the whole time and richie
bogdar our cameraman made that decision
to keep rolling because he he'd already
said to me i was talking to him
yesterday about he said it it was
already eerily quiet so he was he and i
in fact all of us were a bit worried
about where what was happening so he
decided to start rolling and he kept
going and what we have found later and
what we were pretty certain about at the
time is that um civilian cars were being
targeted by unknown gunmen
and a number of families were killed in
cold blood we were driving in an
unmarked family saloon we could have
just been a family there's no possible
way you could have actually seen
accurately uh who was in that car and it
was it was uh fired upon
we i think particularly myself uh
dominique van hood and our producer and
richie were convinced it was a mistake
that it was a ukrainian um militia
checkpoint and we started shouting
journalists
and if anything the firing intensified
after that
um and really the hardest bit was to to
try and get out of the car which you
have you know it's a standard procedure
and you do have to it's called debussing
and we knew we had to do bus um
um two of the team had all had already
got out and the three of us were were
left and it was a matter of of choosing
your moment when to get out and
you know you you talk about choosing a
moment but i mean this is all going so
fast and there's so much firing it's
it's really is luck as if you get out
and i what is it is miraculous
is that
in an ambush scenario like this
five people got out of that car
um richie's [ __ ] he was hiding behind
the engine block wasn't it richie had
got himself he i mean he's a big guy but
he got himself into the well of the of
the passenger seat and basically that
the engine block was saving him
i was watching he you could only see the
camera angry all you can actually see
are the bullets from where his camera is
looking pointing down because he can't
lift his head
but i'm actually onto the back seat in
this sort of position which is where i
was eventually shot
and um i'm watching the uh the
windscreen and then the the the the
driving wheel and then the panel of the
car just completely disintegrate and
fall off and i was like this is
unbelievable and at that point i
remember saying right i know i'm going
to die now i'm not i know i am going to
100
and i remember thinking i wonder how
much it's going to hurt because the the
intensity was such you know it was sort
of i just didn't think i'd be getting
out then i got hit
and actually
i've been asked to describe what it's
like and the best description that it
was put to me is it like this and it is
absolutely true it's like being hit with
a hammer
with sparklers on it fireworks sparklers
so it's
it's cl you know it's it's it we think
that's the flesh burn is sizzling and
that's your flesh
and then you hit with a hammer at the
same time but it wasn't that bad
and i incredibly i remember
putting my helmet on my helmet had been
in
my uh my lap put my helmet on and
realized i could see there was debris
from everywhere in the lots of our kit
cameras and phones
so i went back and picked up my phone
and thought i've got to have the phone
uh
got out of the car and in the footage
they get out of the car i mean you how
did you get out of the car when you were
being shot at yeah and short um um
weirdly
on the rushes and i think it's actually
on one of the pieces you can hear richie
shout what are you doing and apparently
i have no recollection this i got out of
the car and stood up and sort of walked
to the embankment
saw the guys at the bottom it was about
40 feet
down i suppose took a couple of steps
and then dived
i'm pretty certain i knocked myself out
but i can't guarantee it the next minute
i remember is seeing
richie near me but no i'd left before
him i don't think it was not long before
him but um and i know that the guys had
been shouting up to him and he didn't
reply and at that stage everyone assumed
he was hit and possibly had died but he
was he didn't want to reply because he
felt that the firing gone for so long
they would assume he'd been hit or was
dead
and he waited for it to go quiet and
then as soon as he thought right they
they think i'm a goner he then got out
and ran
but and it was only a couple of days
later when we were reviewing the
pictures that as he's running there was
just a hail of bullets they realized
that he was coming so he's extremely
lucky bear in mind richard already been
hit twice in the back it's just his
armor
was was on and saved him because it was
quite high up it would have gone
straight into his lungs yeah so he was
like
and then
this happened
we've got ourselves into a garage
somehow we found our way in there's
three guys working here and they've said
we can stay with a lot of
firing going on outside
um we don't know why
it appears to be
it's a big fight we might even be on the
front line and we're hoping the military
come to get us but who knows
and we talked in the days afterwards
didn't you didn't we and you said you
still you didn't think that you were out
of danger you thought that they were
kind of going to come and get you in
that warehouse absolutely i think
there's often in in various scrapes that
i've been in
after the initial terrible one it
doesn't actually suddenly start getting
any better because we've we i mean we're
very grateful to these three men who let
us into their their warehouse
um
but we were we were really degrading
quite quickly there obviously i was
bleeding not terribly but it was i was
bleeding enough and and we had no water
and we were i mean you can see i look
absolutely terrible i've got terrible
shock there probably concussion
um
and then this fighting started now we to
this day have no idea what was going on
but that was in and out so we sort of
think
that the
the the russian
team
were coming towards us
uh to our position perhaps to finish us
and that another
uh ukrainian unit having heard all the
firing guitar car in the first place had
came had come down the road perhaps just
to see what was happening and engaged
with them because i mean that went on a
long time that it was and
the whole of us being in there lasted
hours and the shooting was a long time
as well that was a proper engagement um
and to be fair to that i mean for all of
us it was that was terrifying
um we were having communications with um
with sky of course and with our sort of
our super fixer who wasn't with us at
that stage azad and he was ringing
everyone he knew so we were beginning to
get communications i mean always thank
goodness i had my phone um or when got
it
and um we were then talking to the
authorities talking to the police and
they said basically we will come
but we won't get you until till the
morning and so we sort of prepared
ourselves to to to bed down we went into
a small room within this warehouse
and were prepared
to stay there for the night it was but
it was it it was one of those ones that
we were
uh very concerned that you know we'd
even wake up in the morning and not be
surrounded um but we we understood it
was dark outside by this stage it was
dangerous driving around it would be
dangerous in the police and one of the
reasons that you wanted to tell the
story was because of the suffering that
the people of ukraine are going through
and i specifically particularly remember
the 21 year old soldier that was on the
bridge on his own tell me about that
yeah he was an amazing guy we were we we
were uh filming
um
a variety of elements but we went up to
actually get a nice picture from from
some of the bridges that are important
in kiev the significance being is if if
the russians can get across the bridges
they're right into the centre of town so
the east and the west of the city are
effectively controlled by those bridges
that's why we had gone there
and this boy was was guarding uh the
bridge on his own he was quite friendly
he said you can stay with me you can
film but you know you have to leave you
spoke very good english
and we were just chatting to him and
he's explained i think he'd he'd find
his bullets about i think 20
bullets he'd ever shot in his life
should we listen to him say
russian base in my village
and
from my village they're gonna
go here on the kiu
to capture it
yeah it's really
scary and terrifying i am
called to my parents
they
really scared
there's russians in our village enemies
there's
tanks
heavy vehicle
i hope that
they will be fine
21 years old younger than both our sons
very brave very brave and um interesting
his story was absolutely viral it was
just a quick interview and i think you
know what one of the uh social media is
something like 31 million views of of
his his comments and he is sums up
people um he he was he's not a soldier
clearly he's not a soldier but he's just
doing doing the right thing um and he's
talked about his parents being
surrounded by by russians and the reason
we were doing the story and the reason
why we wanted to put the story of us
being attacked is that this is what is
happening today people and there have
been other incidents and they're
happening right now we heard of one uh
yesterday almost identical almost
identical family in a car all dead and
um
of course we've got
there are many other elements of the war
that are going on which isn't just
people being shot in a small numbers but
in large numbers and obviously the
horrendous
life for them in in places like mario
paul where they're being bombed uh in
out of existence horrendous and you and
alex crawford and your teams always put
yourselves in danger so that our sky
news viewers right around the world can
find out what is happening and
particularly a story that stands out for
me was when you were on the roof
in afghanistan in kabul i'm sure you
remember exactly what i'm talking about
let's remind our viewers what happened
i hear a lot of shouting uh
coming down the road behind me in fact
it is a
i think it's a procession of
of the taliban
yes it is there's the white flag
and
they're coming down
the street
uh just next to us they're in their
xiaowakamis they're led by a white flag
and they're chanting
as they as they go
go down
cool as a cucumber
i didn't feel it at the time
i bet you didn't what were you thinking
well we did you know we knew they were
coming it had been getting closer and
closer for days you know we'd had all
these this this intelligence briefings
all from the
foreign governments the united states
that
uh britain that you know kabul would
hold for weeks etc it was like quite
clear to us by about the thursday that
it was going to go
and then i think it was on the saturday
morning i think that was a saturday um
it was like we know that um we're
completely surrounded and it was a real
case of what's it going to be like you
know what's going what what will happen
when they come in um and actually it it
it was very different to what we
expected
um and they they actually were quite um
the taliban were very controlled in the
first early days
um but you know in the in i was glad i
was actually on on air to be honest
because
waiting to be on or just sitting in the
hotel was actually terrifying it was
better to be up and running and working
and um
leave you stayed and you carried on with
our coverage and to that end uh skye has
been nominated for bafta today i'm sure
you're aware of that
the end game and we've got an image
of when you were on the ground talking
to local people
you know there's another group this is
women in children you see this all the
time women and children just in huge
huge numbers
yes
they're getting the system done
yes
it's getting better but you know
it feels more like a
a desperate
evacuation now
than at any given point you can just
feel the desperation it's it's quite
remarkable and i think everyone here
knows
you know it's we're only days now games
until the flight stopped
lots of people asked me i had so i'm
sure you were bombarded as were the
others um covering events like this
your bravery
are you aware that you're being brave at
the time no not at all no not at all um
uh in fact i'm really not a very brave
person oh come on no i don't seriously
not i do we we do this and i could have
been asked a lot why do you do it um
because actually i believe and i don't
get all too high for looting about this
but we are somebody has to bear witness
to what's going on it's a well said
statement but it's absolutely true and
lots of my friends have died doing
exactly that
and it is it's upsetting when that
happens and a friend was buried uh
yesterday in fact pierre who was well
known to the people at skyward fox
so you know
we have to do or we want to do this job
and the people who do it all feel
exactly the same you have to bear
witness now you get yourself into
position so you can
do that job
inevitably though they are often quite
dangerous and you try to
mitigate mitigate for that and try to to
make sure that the the risk is as small
as possible but there is inevitably
going to be uh some risk and and it is
interesting with the afghanistan because
i was asked did you ever think of
leaving um
prior to them arriving and i mean the
only answer is
i was i was there to see them arrive so
no
there's no point what was the point of
me leaving i shouldn't have gone and
that's one of those those instances we
did we were leaving for example within
ukraine the battlefield to go back to
hotel because it was too dangerous
so if you if you see we hadn't gone
looking for trouble it it it came to you
came to us and i think that's what
happens in a lot of these times so it's
not bravery it just comes to you and i
think i'm saying that you've been this
guy 30 years today well apparently it's
30 years today which is obviously a life
sentence or even longer
i was going to say happy anniversary but
maybe that's not quite the right
phraseology to use but are there any
particular incidents that stand out for
you
um well i mean there is a number um
a lot of them some some really nice
obviously some great interviews and
people i've met and and and stories
where we've helped people but a few
nightmare ones obviously this was one
yeah i'm thinking about mosul in
particular mosul
one was terrible with cameraman nathan
hale again we weren't looking for
trouble and got ourselves into a live
stream this is what happened
what
are you okay yeah you ready yeah i'm
okay
you okay hey have you
you should go you've already done that
okay give me
yeah
but enormous explosion has just come
down i think it was a monster just
landed in between us
you can see the whole place is uh
covered in smoke
this is the bomb from islamic state's
own drone pictures released on social
media
it is chaotic everyone is dazed but we
are being attacked still
[Applause]
the whizzing is incoming
through the smoke the walking wound did
come looking for him
at the time i didn't think it could have
got any closer than that no i i you
would have i must admit i think i i'd
have said that that was the worst it was
ever going to be and this one was easily
far far worse classic uh example of this
of where that initial explosion and huge
huge explosion that it was and it killed
i mean dozens and dozens of people we
were very very lucky but i mean what
happened afterwards was actually it was
even worse i mean we were running around
uh rubble being shot at for what felt
like hours it was certainly a long time
and eventually we we we were able to
escape but you know
that you'd have thought that the blast
would have been the end of it but it it
really really wasn't and uh yeah we we
had to um
uh eventually get out and there's this
uh missiles
flying over us
all the time etc as well i think
actually this was us actually going on
the way in would you believe this is us
when we were trying to get through the
rubble a lot of fighting going on
islamic state were all round and then
the helicopters are put up by the um
iraqi forces to protect them but the
problem with that is they have to shoot
everything so basically
their own soldiers take cover as best
they can but anyone moving around gets
shot so really dangerous and the threat
of death comes from lots of different
avenues and i'm thinking about what
happened when you went to italy i mean
multi-award-winning coverage for that
let's just remind our viewers what
happened there
they're fighting a war here and they are
losing
the sheer numbers of people succumbing
to the corona virus is overwhelming
every hospital in northern italy
the staff are working flat out trying to
keep these people from deteriorating
further
they're trying to stop them from dying
this isn't an intensive care unit it's
an emergency ward the icu is full
people have only just arrived here and
they're in terrible shape
this is an absolute constant this killer
pandemic is virtually out of control
the patients are literally gasping for
air
and the spectra of covid was paralyzing
the country the world at them at that
time and yet you once again went towards
danger what's in your brain what makes
you do that we had no one had seen
a a an icu or in that case what looked
like an icu but was actually as i said
the emergency ward we'd not seen it
and there were a lot of skeptics and um
we it took an awful lot of work to get
us in i know an awful lot of people
wouldn't have done it and i talked to
our bosses in the in the in the hours as
we were leading up and and i talked to
the head of news the other day about it
john riley who was saying he came very
near to saying i'm not letting you go in
but we pretty much convinced him that we
thought it was the right thing we had
been trained you know we had we did have
the right gear on we didn't know much
about the virus at all let's be honest
at that stage nobody knew anything and i
think in terms of important stories i
you know the first proper pandemic in
100 years the first it's ever been a
television pandemic
i was very proud for us to have gone and
done that the first time anyone had seen
now everyone's done it since and the
story's changed and hard to believe
really in in two years and here we are i
mean sky news has a lot of con controls
because of our work uh practices but
outside you would never know there had
been a virus of course there really is
one still and it's very very dangerous
still but it's russia that um invading
ukraine which has brought you with us
today and uh we are hearing that the
russians are moving away from kiev and
the like and the big question is uh
should the world believe russia when he
says that when it says that's what it's
going to do i did actually put that to
the deputy prime minister earlier on and
this is what he had to say
we judge
the russian military machine by its
actions not just its words there's
obviously some skepticism that it will
regroup to attack again
rather than seriously engage in
diplomacy or anything of that nature um
of course the the door to diplomacy will
always be left ajar but i don't think
you can trust what is coming out of the
mouth of putin's war machine
and to that end we have taken the
opportunity to bring in the ukrainian
ambassador to the uk mr ambassador thank
you for taking the time to join us again
i know you did want to just say a couple
of words to stuart didn't you
we had a chance just to chat a couple of
minutes before the before interview
started and i told him that i'm very
proud to to actually be able to meet
with him
and to tell you that you have very brave
and a bit crazy in good sense people to
do the job and thank you for for coming
for doing this and understand how
important all those to all these people
including this young soldier to know
that their story is hurt
well we we really appreciate it and you
know it is it's been an amazing event
for us to to to be in ukraine and to
meet the people and and amazing stories
of of of people
that have it that has gone on for years
when i was there 2014 so it's it's it's
not a new story but um
the incredible resilience um
of the people particularly well
throughout the country has been
remarkable to report on actually the
party told me about that's the usual car
you were driving yeah and the people
could be in there just just families and
be targeted that's something we wanted
people here to hear to understand that
actually this is dangerous just for
civilians and i i asked you about the
protective gears you had and that's the
stopped couple of bullets in your people
so that's why we are going here and
drastically asking and begging for the
protective gears for military for
medical stuff for firefighters for first
responders for journalists like you just
to save lives and they're actually
saving lives yes absolutely 100
um
i'm sure britain will be sending yeah
and as stuart was saying you know we've
we've seen colleagues die um in almost
exact same circumstances pierre you were
talking about from fox
that's right and and you know
i mean
the point is that journalists talking
about themselves is always rather
embarrassing but a large number have
died
at a rate unusual in most wars which we
we cover a lot of
obviously it pales into insignificance
with the civilian population but yeah
the the the these incidents that that
we've talked about which effectively
ours with with people actually being
targeted i mean it is a disgrace because
clearly these people particularly
families are not a threat to anyone and
and pretty much anyone with a weapon
would know they're not a threat um and
and and that is
that is a big problem and it's not
getting any easier mr master do you
believe russia when it says that it is
moving away from kiev and other peace
talks do seem to be working frankly we
don't believe russians at all not me
personally and
i think that they're just maneuvering
trying to regain their their strengths
because as we've seen there because
we've been beaten quite quite heavily by
ukrainian forces especially around big
cities so i guess they will regroup and
will come again and again and again
that's what they're doing it's not just
this work they've been doing for
centuries
what's your view on the suggestions that
at the ukrainian delegation were
poisoned when they were taking part in
the peace talks
i don't wish anybody bad i mean if if
they feel it's this way but frankly
speaking i guess if russians wanted them
to be poisoned to death they would be
dead by now
and remember how the people who drank
polonium here how this kripal's family
was was poisoned and how so many people
suffered around this so
i i i believe that
it will come sooner or later russians
will do something like that and people
asking me for example yeah if i'm secure
here
they have protection and everything i
believe that we can't be filled can feel
protected anyway around the globe when
russians are going in such a scaled
operation against ukraine and actually
again against the whole world and i
thought for the people of ukraine as
they continue to suffer five weeks on
we just you know had this month which
was on the third last thursday the how
people are surviving all these months of
of the bombardment and shelling and
everything we had this war for eight
years but it was somewhere in east of
ukraine somewhere far from cities like
kiev and people were having more or less
normal life now this the whole broke the
whole hell broke out and everybody
seemed three million already across the
borders people are living it's deserting
the nation and we're still fighting some
of the journalists like you are now
fighting
some of them became an operator so the
anti-tank rockets that people all from
all professional blocks of life have to
protect their nation and you believe
when we started talking to you not many
people believed when i was saying
that it won't be walk in the park people
like yeah yeah
but that's actually what was happening
we're still fighting we hope that you
know it's very difficult to believe but
we can actually defeat russians we can
actually win this war okay um let's see
what happens in the coming weeks mr
ambassador thank you for taking the time
to join us on the programme this morning
thank you please don't do it again
and
30th anniversary as i said i don't know
what's going to happen next i'm not
going to put you on the spot and ask you
on the telly but yeah yeah
let's see but um thank you for
recounting uh what happened and i know
that you really wanted to make the point
that it's not about you it's not about
the crew it's about telling the story of
the people of ukraine and the struggles
that they are facing day after day after
day and in every story we do they're
always about people not us okay thank
you both